[MUSIC PLAYING]
KIT MERKER: GCP
NEXT 2016, day two.
We're here in San
Francisco, California.
I'm Kit.
BRAD ABRAMS: And
I'm Brad, and we're
going to be your hosts for
this GCP NEXT livestream.
Yesterday, we had over
10,000 people join us online.
KIT MERKER: Yeah, and
the content yesterday
was fantastic.
I really enjoyed the keynotes.
What did you think, Brad?
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
It was great to see
Eric Schmidt and Sundar
Pichai talk about how
the Cloud platform fits
into Google All Up.
KIT MERKER: Yup.
Yeah, that's right.
We're right now standing in
what's called the Treehouse.
Yesterday it was the Playground.
Today, we're in the Treehouse.
And this is where the
partners are all set up.
We're going to go
talk with them later.
But, you know,
remember yesterday, you
got to get your picture
taken and had machine
learning process your face?
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh, yeah.
That was really cool.
And we played the quiz
show game for BigQuery.
But unfortunately, Kit won.
So we're going to have
to do a rematch later.
KIT MERKER: Yeah.
Challenge accepted.
We also toured the data center.
We got to go and do the 360
tour of the data center.
Really fun.
Those of you at home,
you can do that too.
Check it out on
YouTube-- the 360 tour.
So, you know, we've
been talking enough.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes.
KIT MERKER: We should probably
talk to these nice folks that
were here yesterday.
They want to chat
with you a little bit
about their experience
at NEXT so far.
Hey, guys, come on in.
BRAD ABRAMS: Hey, welcome.
Good to see you.
Thanks.
So, I understand you run the
Codelabs here for GCP NEXT.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
We've had a ton of people
come and enjoy the Codelabs
because we got some
of the new topics,
like Kubernetes and the Vision
API that you can come and get
your hands on and try
it out right away.
And people are really liking it.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
I was walking by the
Codelabs yesterday,
and I saw a line of
people waiting to do--
MALE SPEAKER: It's
been full, yeah.
It's sometimes first-come,
first-serve, and sitting room
only, so yeah.
BRAD ABRAMS: Awesome.
KIT MERKER: So, for
people that aren't here
in person who are
on the livestream--
can they go check it out, too?
Where do they go?
MALE SPEAKER: They
can go to gcplab.me
to try out all the
Codelabs for themselves.
BRAD ABRAMS: All right.
That's fantastic.
KIT MERKER: Great.
Thank you.
BRAD ABRAMS: So thanks
a lot for being with us.
I understand you're
a GCP customer?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
no, I've been a GCP
customer for a few years now.
And when I saw the
chance to come to NEXT,
I just thought, why not?
You know, it was one of
those things, where I'm like,
this is an amazing company.
And this conference was,
like, what I live and breathe.
BRAD ABRAMS: All right.
Fantastic.
KIT MERKER: Do you have
any, like, takeaways?
What did you think of
the content yesterday?
MALE SPEAKER: You know, I
really enjoyed the keynote,
Eric Schmidt.
It was, you know,
very, very punctual.
And a lot of the
new technologies
that were announced
yesterday were amazing.
I was literally
taking notes while I
was watching the keynote
because there's things
that I'm going to use.
So it was one of
those things that
just got me really excited.
KIT MERKER: Yeah, when
we were chatting before,
you said you were thinking about
using Vision API in a new app.
What are you going to do?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, no, I mean,
the Vision API is going to help
us because we're-- my
company, [INAUDIBLE],
is going to have to filter
through user-generated content
and imagery.
So we're talking about probably
hundreds of thousands of images
that we're going to
have to look through.
And we were trying to
think of this way of going
through that content without
having to spend hundreds
of man hours trying to come
up with a developer solution
to get rid of the content
that we don't need.
And it was like a sign,
the Google Vision API.
I saw that.
I was like--
BRAD ABRAMS: Came in at
exactly the right time.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm like,
was I meant to come here
and see this?
It was one of those things.
And then when they announced it
and showed me and did a selfie
on stage, and it just
filtered out and said,
you know, there's
a face, there's
a stage, all those
things-- it was like, dude,
this is-- for a small
development company
and somebody who deals
with imagery, I'm like,
this would have taken
us hundreds of man hours
and a very large investment.
And Google did it for us in a
very nice, real-time manner,
giving us back the
code and stuff.
BRAD ABRAMS: So you got a chance
to do a few of the Codelabs.
Did you do a Codelab
with the Vision API?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
I did a Codelab
with the Vision API.
I got to do some
actually load balancing.
It was Codelabs.
So it was really amazing
to get there and sit down
with some developers and
answer the questions that I've
had for things that I've
been like, eh, do I do this?
Do I do that?
I was on the fence
on a lot of things.
And doing the
Codelabs, it answered
a lot of questions for me and
gave me a bunch of new ideas.
I want to go out and work
with a lot of the new Google
services and stuff,
and get things
going on my company
in a new direction.
MALE SPEAKER: And I
should say that there's
a whole range Codelabs,
of technical levels
in the Codelabs.
So if you're a beginner,
there's stuff for you.
If you're advanced, there's
stuff for you to check out.
So please.
BRAD ABRAMS: So give them
the URL for the Codelab one
more time.
I think they're sold now.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Gcplab.me.
KIT MERKER: Very cool.
BRAD ABRAMS: You can
do that right after you
watch the livestream here.
KIT MERKER: That's right.
Hey, one last question
for you, [INAUDIBLE].
You're here in person.
Our friends here are online.
Should they think
about coming in person?
What's the difference?
What do you think?
MALE SPEAKER: That
was one of the things
that I thought about.
I thought, well, I could
just watch it online.
But the thing is, I mean, I had
a bunch of specific questions
for developers that only Google
Developers could actually
answer.
And it was one of things.
And, I mean, just sitting
in the sessions here,
I've gotten 15, 20
new ideas of ways
I can use Google technology to
improve my company's business
strategy and speed things up
and do things here and there.
So, yeah, I mean,
watching online is great.
But, I mean, I like digging in
and asking questions and trying
to stump the developers.
So it's one of those things.
Coming here and
doing the Codelabs
and meeting the
partners-- it just seemed
like such a great idea.
KIT MERKER: Well, and the
party was fun, too, wasn't it?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, it
was a little too much fun.
KIT MERKER: Well, thanks, guys,
so much for chatting with us.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes, thanks a lot.
Really appreciate it.
Enjoy the rest of the show.
KIT MERKER: All right.
So we're going to move on here.
And we're going to chat with--
BRAD ABRAMS: We're going
to chat with Bo over here.
He's going to give us an
overview of what we're
doing here in the
Treehouse where we're
talking to all our partners.
KIT MERKER: Bo, how are you
doing this morning, sir?
BO: What's up, Kit?
How are you doing?
KIT MERKER: Doing well.
BO: Good.
Good to see you guys.
BRAD ABRAMS: So Bo, tell
us, what is this all about?
BO: So this is the Treehouse.
So welcome to the Treehouse.
As you saw up front-- it's like,
up front is the playground.
You play games.
You have a good time.
It's like you goof
around with your friends.
What we envisioned
for the Treehouse
was something that
was a place where
you could share ideas,
talk about big things,
and really collaborate
together to build hopefully
the next big thing.
So what you'll see here is
a ton of our partners that
are floating around, also
a lot of our team members
talking about how they can
integrate and work better
together.
BRAD ABRAMS: That's
pretty awesome.
KIT MERKER: Very cool.
BRAD ABRAMS: So I see this board
over here that's pretty cool.
Should we go check that out?
BO: Yeah, absolutely.
So what we have here is before
the start of the conference,
we actually polled a lot
of our audience members
to see what exactly you cared
about learning more about.
So what [? workloads ?]
means something to you?
So these were the specific
ones that popped up.
And ultimately,
what we made here
is a lot of just
architecture diagrams of what
you can see, how to build
it, and gain inspiration.
KIT MERKER: So if I
wanted to check out,
like, financial
services, for example.
BO: Yeah, exactly.
So you just walk up here.
You mash the financial
services button.
And these are the
two biggest cases
that we're going to see coming
across our interwebs right now.
And so if we click the
Monte Carlo simulations--
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh,
that's a good one.
BO: --then we're
going to pop up.
And you're going to see
all of our products,
how they integrate and
work together, as well
as all of our partners, and how
they plug into those scenarios.
KIT MERKER: [INAUDIBLE].
BRAD ABRAMS: All right, great.
Let's try Pivotal.
BO: Yup.
And so, within
this space, you'll
see exactly what Pivotal does
within the financial services
industry.
So from here, you can go and
talk to Pivotal over there,
and you'll see
exactly what they do.
BRAD ABRAMS: And what
we're seeing here
is like an architecture diagram
of how you might do Monte Carlo
simulation on our platform.
BO: Exactly.
That's exactly it.
And then if you want
to save it for later,
you can either take a photo
with your phone, scan a QR code,
or even check out some
of the relevant sessions
to figure out when and
where you can actually
go learn more about this.
BRAD ABRAMS: Huh,
that's really cool.
KIT MERKER: This is awesome.
I've seen a lot of people
coming up and using
this to figure stuff out.
We've got people on the
livestream right now.
How do they interact with this?
BO: So right now, you can go
to cloud.google.com/solutions.
A lot of these diagrams
are there and online.
So you can browse
them for yourselves.
And if you're looking
for the partners,
you can go to
cloud.google.com/partners.
KIT MERKER: Fantastic.
BRAD ABRAMS: That sounds great.
KIT MERKER: Should we go
talk to some partners, Brad?
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah, I'm
pretty excited to hear
from some partners.
So let's walk around and
see what we can find.
KIT MERKER: Thank
you so much, Bo.
BO: Hey, have fun.
KIT MERKER: Thanks.
All right.
BRAD ABRAMS: Thanks.
KIT MERKER: So we're just going
to go chat with some people.
BRAD ABRAMS: All right.
Let's see who we
can find right now.
KIT MERKER: Hi there, Jessica?
Hey, I'm Kit.
Nice to see you.
JESSICA: Nice to see you.
KIT MERKER: So
welcome to GCP NEXT.
JESSICA: Woo-hoo!
KIT MERKER: Say hello
to the livestream.
JESSICA: Hi guys.
How are you doing?
KIT MERKER: So tell
us a little bit.
Why are you here?
What are you guys doing?
JESSICA: Yeah.
Tableau helps people
see and understand data.
Google is full of data.
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh, yeah.
JESSICA: We worked
really close with you
guys to make sure we have
direct connects, like Google
Analytics, Google BigQuery,
Google Cloud, SQL, you name it,
along with many
other data sources.
So, really, just
helping the end user
take all that data
and visualize it.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
So if I have all my
data in BigQuery,
you can make it look beautiful,
so I can get reports and charts
and whatnot.
JESSICA: Yes.
Not only beautiful,
but interactive.
And I think that's important.
It allows you to
ask more questions
about what's in your data.
BRAD ABRAMS: Right.
That whole, how you can
go from data to insights.
JESSICA: Yes.
Ask more questions,
learn more, right?
MALE SPEAKER: So what are
your takeaways from the event
so far?
How have you been
experiencing it?
JESSICA: I love
how organic it is.
I'm digging that it's
not, you know, stiff.
[LAUGHTER]
I love the view, too.
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh, yeah.
The view's fantastic.
I appreciate the view.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
JESSICA: And great people.
Just love hearing the use cases
that everybody's coming with.
Like, I just met with
somebody with a government use
case, somebody else with
marketing use cases,
you name it.
So just keeping it real.
KIT MERKER: Fantastic.
Thanks so much for
chatting with us.
JESSICA: Thanks.
KIT MERKER: All right.
We'll see you later.
OK.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
Thanks a lot.
KIT MERKER: Thanks
for being here.
All right, let's just
come around this way.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
Let's see what else we can find.
KIT MERKER: And--
BRAD ABRAMS: We're going
to keep walking around
the Treehouse here
and see if we can find
some more partners to talk to.
KIT MERKER: Hello, folks.
Would you like to
talk to the internet?
Say hello to the internet.
Hi, I'm Kit.
EMILY: Emily.
KIT MERKER: Nice to meet you.
EMILY: Nice to meet you.
KIT MERKER: So tell
us about your company
and what you're doing
here with Google.
EMILY: So this is also Ed.
I'll bring him in.
ED: Hey, how's it going?
BRAD ABRAMS: All right, Ed.
ED: I'm Ed.
KIT MERKER: Hey.
ED: Nice to meet you.
KIT MERKER: Likewise.
BRAD ABRAMS: We have
our livestream here--
ED: Hey, live stream.
BRAD ABRAMS: Viewers
all over the world.
ED: Hey, viewers
KIT MERKER: So tell
us a little bit
about what you guys are doing--
Fastly-- what you guys are
doing with Google Cloud.
ED: Sure.
So, we're Fastly.
We're a content
delivery network.
And we've integrated into
the Google Cloud in 14 points
all around the world to be the
delivery component up in front
of Google Cloud Storage
and Google Cloud Platform.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
Great.
KIT MERKER: So for
users out there
that want to know how
they could use Fastly,
what are you guys going
to solve for them?
What are the problems
you really look at?
ED: So we ensure that you get a
speedy and consistent delivery
of any assets that
you're hosting
on Google Cloud Platform
or in Google Cloud Storage.
A lot of these customers
are video customers
or retailers or publishers
that have a lot of assets.
We just stream out to
the rest of the world.
KIT MERKER: What's your
take on the event so far?
What are you experiencing?
ED: I'm loving the event.
I've never been in
this venue before.
I live in San Francisco.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
ED: And it's great to
see our Google family
walking around, and--
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh, yeah.
ED: --with the partner
ecosystem, too.
We see these people
all over the world.
I've seen them in Tokyo and
in Amsterdam and London.
And it's really great to
see everyone in my hometown.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah, yeah.
And there's something about
this atmosphere of Pier 48,
too, right, that
really feels good.
ED: It's pretty sweet.
BRAD ABRAMS: So what
are some use cases
that customers have
come up and asked about?
Are there things
that are resonating?
ED: A lot of customers
are asking us
about video streaming.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK, yeah.
ED: A lot of customers are
creating exciting entertainment
properties, and--
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
Like, for example, if you
were putting on a conference
and you wanted to have a
livestream for 10,000 people--
ED: Yeah, who would
ever want to do that?
I don't know who would
want to do that--
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah,
that's great, yeah.
ED: But let's just
say you wanted
to have a bunch of
people stream something.
BRAD ABRAMS: Right.
ED: That's a common
use case for us.
BRAD ABRAMS: All right.
Great.
That's very cool.
KIT MERKER: OK, very cool.
Let's see.
Let's move on.
What do you think?
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
Yeah.
KIT MERKER: Well, thanks
so much for chatting.
Have a great day.
ED: Yeah, thanks a lot.
BRAD ABRAMS: Take
care, you guys.
ED: I appreciate talking to you.
Yeah.
Thanks.
KIT MERKER: So--
BRAD ABRAMS: All right, so
where should we go next, Kit?
KIT MERKER: Let's
go over this way.
Let's see who we're gonna pick--
BRAD ABRAMS: Follow
us, we're gonna
find some more
partners to talk to.
KIT MERKER: Why don't we check
out-- should we chat with Scalr
over here?
BRAD ABRAMS: All right.
KIT MERKER: Is this guy ready?
I don't know.
Yeah, let's-- why not.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
KIT MERKER: Hey, can I
interrupt you guys for a second?
Sorry, we have--
BRAD ABRAMS: So we have--
KIT MERKER: I have
10,000 people here.
BRAD ABRAMS: We have 10,000
people on livestream.
We thought we'd come over and
chat with you for a minute.
KIT MERKER: Hi, there.
Can you introduce yourself?
MALE SPEAKER: Chat with
our [? product marketing ?]
[? manager. ?]
KIT MERKER: Come on over.
BRAD ABRAMS: All right.
KIT MERKER: Hi, there.
Introduce yourself.
RON HARNIK: My
name is Ron Harnik.
I'm a product marketing
manager for Scalr.
BRAD ABRAMS: All right, great.
So tell us what Scalr does,
and how you're integrating
with the cloud platform.
RON HARNIK: So Scalr is a
policy-driven cloud management
platform.
So it means that,
for example, you
have multiple different
clouds in your organization,
Scalr creates an environment
where end users can
operate freely out of
a self-service catalog,
just pick and choose
their applications
and deploy their applications.
And Scalr takes care
of all the policy
that needs to be around that.
So, for example, you have
Team A and Team B. Team
A needs to be able to
operate on a large budget
and consume infrastructure
templates that they create,
and whatever size of virtual
machine that they need.
And Team B needs to have
access to the same GC
account, GC project,
for example,
but on a smaller budget.
And they can only provision
smaller-sized virtual machines.
And so Scalr takes care of all
of that policy around that,
gives you single sign-on
for multiple clouds--
GCE, AWS, all the
major cloud platforms.
That is like the short,
short, short pitch.
KIT MERKER: Cool.
Yeah.
So in terms of the event
today and yesterday,
what's your one takeaway
for the folks online?
RON HARNIK: My one
takeaway from-- it's
definitely that GCE I think is
on the rise as a huge platform.
I've been using it
myself for a while.
It's a lot faster.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah, so
Scalr works really well
with AWS and Azure.
RON HARNIK: Yeah.
BRAD ABRAMS: But with GCE,
is there anything different,
in your experience
working with GCE?
RON HARNIK: Well-- well,
my experience with GCE
is really just the-- how
agile it is, how fast it is,
how fast you can
actually get going.
So it's a lot easier
to get started with,
and I think agility is
probably my main takeaway.
So for example,
the demo machines
that we have running here,
we put them all on GCE
because we thought
it's appropriate.
But then we saw like, man,
this took, like, a minute.
KIT MERKER: Yeah.
RON HARNIK: So--
BRAD ABRAMS: That's the
speed of spinning up
a large number of
VMs and whatnot--
RON HARNIK: Yeah,
it's also-- but moving
storage around, and
it's more than just,
like, spinning up the VM.
Orchestrating
something onto GCE,
for example,
orchestrating, like,
Kubernetes cluster
onto GCE, using that,
shifting things around.
It's just how fast
everything is is incredible.
The fastest I've
had experience with.
BRAD ABRAMS: Awesome.
KIT MERKER: Wow, great.
Well, thanks for
chatting with us.
Thanks for being here.
RON HARNIK: Sure.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah,
enjoy the conference.
KIT MERKER: So I think we're--
I want to kind of cross
the street here because we're
hanging out on this side.
Why don't we walk
back this way and see
what's going on on the other
side, if that's all right.
BRAD ABRAMS: All right, yeah,
so we're actually going to--
KIT MERKER: Oh, by
the way, I wanted
to mention for those of you out
there, if you're on Twitter,
hit us up on hashtag #GCPNEXT.
Let's trend this thing, right?
BRAD ABRAMS: All right, great.
Yeah.
So we're going to walk
across the way here.
And you can see people are
streaming into the keynote.
If you're just joining us,
we're hosting a livestream.
The keynote will be
beginning in just a minute.
KIT MERKER: Let's come
over here toward this side.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
KIT MERKER: You know--
BRAD ABRAMS: So we can
see all these people are
going into the keynote now.
KIT MERKER: We're going to swim
upstream here against the crowd
heading toward the keynote.
You guys will get to see the
keynote in just a few minutes
after we chat with
some more partners.
BRAD ABRAMS: So you can see
there's a rich ecosystem
of partners for GCP.
And many of them
have come out and are
engaging with customers that
are here at the conference.
So let's see who we can find--
KIT MERKER: Why don't we chat
with-- how about Bitnami?
What do you guys think?
BRAD ABRAMS: Bitnami
sounds fantastic.
KIT MERKER: I'll just catch you
guys-- you want to talk, David?
DAVID: Sure.
Hi.
KIT MERKER: Say hello
to the livestream.
You're on live right now.
DAVID: Hi, livestream.
How are you guys doing?
Hello, world.
KIT MERKER: So Bitnami and
Google-- Bitnami and Google
Cloud, tell us about it.
Does it work together?
DAVID: Yeah.
So there's basically two things
we have going on with Bitnami.
One's the base case,
but then we can walk you
through the
container-centric one.
Generally, Bitnami
makes applications
available on Google Cloud.
So you can go ahead and
launch them on Google Cloud
and, with one click, they
deploy straight to Google Cloud.
But we've got something
better we can show you.
KIT MERKER: Oh, wait--
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh, bring
the camera over here.
KIT MERKER: OK,
bring the camera.
He's got something sneaky here.
DAVID: OK.
So, you see OK?
You see the monitor?
OK.
BRAD ABRAMS: We're taking
care of you, livestream.
DAVID: Yeah, we're livestream.
OK.
So recently, back in
November at Dockercon,
we basically released what
was called Stacksmith.
And Stacksmith was designed to
address issues with how do I
update containers?
And how do I do
it in a way that's
capable of scaling,
capable of being automated,
and capable of giving me
a notification that lets
me know when I need to do this?
So this is kind of like your
basic lifecycle of a container.
And what Stacksmith
does, it allows
you to generate a
base container image.
And then once it gets
into production, what's
going to happen is
that you're going
to get a notification that
Stacksmith has an update.
And we can do this via--
you want me to hold it?
KIT MERKER: No, no, I got it.
Not now.
DAVID: OK.
You're going to
get a notification.
And this can be via a webhook,
we can give you a slack,
you get an email.
And if you want to automate at
this point and send the webhook
over here-- in this
case, to Jenkins--
BRAD ABRAMS: And
rebuild your solution.
DAVID: Rebuild your
solution, and boom,
it's going to deploy
through Kubernetes.
And we get the rolling updates,
and then bam, it's out there.
So this is an automated
no-op scenario that's taking
the stuff that Kubernetes
already does with the rolling
updates, and adding the ability
to just basically do auto new
container creation instead of--
BRAD ABRAMS: This
helps your software
be more live because there's a
dependency change or whatnot,
you help pick that up and--
DAVID: Yeah.
And on top of that, this
becomes a real issue
once you start to get
an environment where
there's a lot of
different variances
in the number of containers.
Like if you've only got two
or three different things
running, you're like,
eh, it's not too bad.
BRAD ABRAMS: Right.
You can manage that.
DAVID: You get in a real
production environment,
you're talking
potentially hundreds
of variants of the containers
between the different versions
of the stack.
And the more
microservice that you
get in terms of how much you
decompose, the worse this gets.
BRAD ABRAMS: Right,
right, right.
DAVID: That was really critical.
KIT MERKER: Well,
so thanks so much,
David, for showing us
what you've got there.
Thanks for being on the stream.
DAVID: OK.
BRAD ABRAMS: Thanks a lot.
We appreciate it.
KIT MERKER: We're
gonna move along.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
You wanna head over here?
KIT MERKER: See you later.
Yeah, we can walk
this way, I think.
So you can see what
we've got going on here.
It's pretty cool.
Hey--
BRAD ABRAMS: Should we
come talk to SendGrid?
KIT MERKER: SendGrid.
Let's talk to them.
Hello.
BRAD ABRAMS: Say hello
to our livestream.
We've got 10,000 people--
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, my gosh.
BRAD ABRAMS: --viewing
this live right now.
We're giving them a feeling for
what the conference is about.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
BRAD ABRAMS: So tell us
a little about SendGrid.
MALE SPEAKER: So SendGrid is an
email infrastructure platform.
So we power companies
like Spotify, Uber.
So whenever you get an automated
receipt, any emails that you
receive via these
companies, they're
all being sent through our
platform, highly scalable
distributed platform.
And we do both transactional
and marketing emails.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
So sending email is actually
a complex thing, right?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
Very complicated, actually.
Part of it is also because
of the way email works,
because a lot of providers
like Gmail or Yahoo,
Outlook require specific
signatures or headers
to be inserted.
So managing all of
those things by yourself
can be very, very complicated.
In fact, that was kind of the
reason why SendGrid was created
in the first place
because our founder faced
the exact same issues.
BRAD ABRAMS: I see.
Great.
KIT MERKER: So, well,
tell us about what are you
experiencing at the event?
What kind of people
are you talking to?
And give people at home a
sense of what's going on.
MALE SPEAKER: So mainly
it's been a lot of users
of the Google Cloud Platform.
We actually have a
promotion going with GCP
where you get $300
worth of GCP credit
if you sign up for
a free account.
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh, great.
MALE SPEAKER: So
generally, a lot
of people are really
interested in,
hey, how can I integrate
really quickly with SendGrid?
How can I integrate it with GCP?
And how do the
two work together?
So we have code samples.
We have a bunch of other
demos that we're showing
people who are interested.
BRAD ABRAMS: And what
kind of solutions
are people asking about?
You mentioned retail--
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
BRAD ABRAMS: Marketing.
What are--
MALE SPEAKER: It can vary.
So some users who,
for example, want
to do basic things
like password reset
emails, sign-up confirmations,
receipts-- or there's
the other side of the marketing
component, which is hey,
I want to start
being able to track
all of my lead
segment and my lists.
So that way I know users who
aren't using our site as much,
I want to bring them
back into the fold.
So how do we create an
effective marketing campaign?
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
Do some growth hacking--
MALE SPEAKER: Exactly.
BRAD ABRAMS: --bring
people back in.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
BRAD ABRAMS: Great.
MALE SPEAKER: And
so questions revolve
around both of those aspects.
KIT MERKER: So you guys are in
Google Cloud Launcher as well.
Is that right?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
That's correct.
KIT MERKER: Can you
tell us about that?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
So we're currently integrated
with Google Cloud Launcher.
Essentially, it involves just
setting a quick configuration
in terms of your
host name and port.
And pretty much
you're good to go.
As long as you have your
API keys via SendGrid,
you can use any of our APIs
on Google Cloud Launcher.
BRAD ABRAMS: I see.
So that's right within
the cloud console
where they're spinning up VMs--
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
BRAD ABRAMS: Right
there, they can go
and say, I want a
SendGrid account.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
BRAD ABRAMS: Great.
MALE SPEAKER: We make
it as easy as possible.
And we love the
partnership with GCP.
BRAD ABRAMS: Great.
Great.
Cool.
KIT MERKER: All right.
Well, thanks so much
for chatting with us.
It's great to see you.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you very much.
KIT MERKER: Yeah.
BRAD ABRAMS: Thanks a lot.
KIT MERKER: So we're gonna
keep-- let's keep moving.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
We're heading this way?
KIT MERKER: Why
don't we go this way?
BRAD ABRAMS: All right.
KIT MERKER: I get to decide.
I have all the power right now.
BRAD ABRAMS: Great.
Great.
KIT MERKER: What do you
think about NodeSource?
Node's like this cool, hip
language and stuff, right?
BRAD ABRAMS: I hear Node is hot.
Hi.
KIT MERKER: Hey, Nathan.
NATHAN: Hi.
KIT MERKER: Hi, I'm Kit.
This is the livestream.
We've got thousands
of people at home.
NATHAN: Hey, guys.
KIT MERKER: Don't be nervous.
You can say hi to
your mom, if you want.
NATHAN: Um, hi.
KIT MERKER: So tell us about
what you're doing here.
NATHAN: What we're doing is
we're doing enterprise Node.js.
So Node is amazing.
It's going-- I mean,
what we're seeing
is a huge insurgence as
far as who's adopting it,
who's using it.
Unfortunately, the
tooling is just not
as mature around the
enterprise solution.
So what we're doing is
actually adding solutions
to make that story a lot better.
BRAD ABRAMS: So what are
some of the main problems
that NodeSource solves for you?
NATHAN: Like debugging
visualizations,
like memory leaks around the
stack traces, heap dumps,
snapshots.
So, yeah.
BRAD ABRAMS: Great.
Great.
KIT MERKER: And what do--
what's been your experience
at the event so far?
Any takeaways?
Or what have you seen?
NATHAN: It's been great.
I mean, as far as to be a
part of this whole community,
just the synergy of ideas,
the sharing, the mind share,
everybody just kind of
like-- the blending of ideas.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah, so I
saw App Engine recently
launched support for Node.js.
NATHAN: Yeah.
BRAD ABRAMS: Are you
seeing a kind of uptick
in usage of Node?
NATHAN: Absolutely.
BRAD ABRAMS: What's
the traffic like?
NATHAN: I mean, the
traffic is just like--
it's kind of like up into the--
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah, yeah.
NATHAN: You know I mean?
Actually, we just partnershipped
with you guys on Monday,
had an official announcement--
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh, great.
NATHAN: --as far as a solution,
as far as official support
with the Google Cloud Platform.
So we've been doing
a lot with it.
I personally have helped
spin up Node on GCP a lot.
And I absolutely love
your guys' cloud.
BRAD ABRAMS: And what
sort of solutions,
you know, like retail
or energy, what
are those domains that
people are using Node.js now?
NATHAN: Node.js is actually
being used for a lot of things.
And I think a lot of it's the
hyper-rapid development cycle.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
Yeah.
NATHAN: But in terms
of the SOA, like
service-oriented
architecture, really it's
a great orchestration
layer, right?
I mean, it's not necessarily
ideal for CPU-bound things.
So if you're going to do
large machine learning or AI,
you probably don't want
to use Node for that.
BRAD ABRAMS: But we
have a great new Vision
API, a machine learning service
that you should use for that.
NATHAN: Yeah, right.
Exactly, right?
So but, I mean, as
far as orchestration,
like web apps, a lot of--
even some [? CRUD ?] stuff,
because of the I/O
layer being removed
with the asynchronous
event loop,
it does a great job of that.
And with the eco-- I
think the big thing
is the ecosystem, with how
JavaScript has naturally been
a very open source community.
There's just a numerous
amount of packages to get up
and running very quickly.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
Absolutely.
KIT MERKER: Very cool.
Let's see.
Thank you so much, Nathan.
NATHAN: Yeah, definitely.
KIT MERKER: We're gonna go.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah, thanks.
Good to talk to you.
Appreciate it.
KIT MERKER: Keep
moving along here.
OK.
BRAD ABRAMS: All right, are we
going to head this way, Kit?
KIT MERKER: Let's
go this way, yeah.
Let's see where we can go.
BRAD ABRAMS: All right,
so we're continuing
to walk around the Treehouse.
KIT MERKER: The Treehouse.
And--
BRAD ABRAMS: If you're
just joining us,
we're giving you
this livestream tour
so you can get a sense for
what's going on at GCP NEXT.
KIT MERKER: And
we're going to go
to the keynote in just a
little bit, just a few minutes
from now.
But let's see if we can
chat with some more people.
Excuse me, gentlemen,
would you guys
like to talk to the internet?
BRAD ABRAMS: We have
the GCP NEXT livestream.
We have 10,000 viewers
live right now.
KIT MERKER: Here, let
me stand over here.
BRAD ABRAMS: So tell us a little
bit about what's going on here.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Techquila is a
technology which brings
an on-demand supercomputer
to every single desk.
So this truly revolutionizes
simulation and analysis.
So high-performance computing
and big simulations,
they have been exclusive to
people who have had several
PhDs--
BRAD ABRAMS: Right.
Right.
MALE SPEAKER: --and
special training.
This integrates the power
directed to MATLAB or Python
and all the standard tools.
And you do not need to
have any special training.
When you need to have a
2.5-day simulation done in four
minutes, with this thing and the
power of Google Cloud Platform,
you can get that done.
And that's possible.
BRAD ABRAMS: Wow.
MALE SPEAKER: And you
just pay as you go.
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh, right.
Yeah, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: No
upfront investments.
KIT MERKER: How do you get
started on Techquila on GCP?
What's the best way to do that?
MALE SPEAKER: Go to
Google Cloud Launcher,
Google's new marketplace.
Click, click, click, and you
are live in couple of minutes.
BRAD ABRAMS: So they just write
a MATLAB script or whatever,
and then you actually
run that across--
if you need to spin up 100
or 10,000 GC instances--
MALE SPEAKER: This,
everything runs
on your own Google account.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So this
is a secular thing.
This is always
under your control.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK.
Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: And the
power integrates directly
to MATLAB on your
own PC, on your desk.
And this offloads the
computational workload to GCP.
And if you get the results
back as if the simulation would
be run locally on your PC,
but just 1,000 times faster.
KIT MERKER: So tell us about
your experience at the event.
What have you seen?
Give our folks at home
a sense of being here.
What have you seen?
MALE SPEAKER: Well, this
is an awesome event.
Great speakers and a lot
of innovative people.
So this is awesome, brilliant.
I'm so happy that I flew
from Europe here and have
the possibility to be here and,
like, breathe this whole thing.
This is awesome.
Thanks, all.
KIT MERKER: Very good.
Very good.
BRAD ABRAMS: That was great.
KIT MERKER: Hey,
thank you so much.
It was great chatting with you.
BRAD ABRAMS: Appreciate
talking to you.
MALE SPEAKER: See you all.
KIT MERKER: All
right, let's see.
Let's--
BRAD ABRAMS: OK, so where
are we heading next, Kit?
KIT MERKER: I'm looking over.
Do we have time?
Yeah, we have time.
OK, cool.
Let's keep going.
Let's go chat with HashiCorp.
BRAD ABRAMS: HashiCorp.
KIT MERKER: What do you think?
BRAD ABRAMS: That sounds great.
KIT MERKER: Yeah, let's do it.
So if you're just
joining, we're going
to go to the general
session soon.
We're walking around.
We're in San Francisco, Pier 48.
This is Brad.
I'm Kit.
OK, we're being told
that we actually
need to wrap it up now.
So we won't get to HashiCorp.
But we'll save
that for next time.
So we're going to go to
the general session in just
a second.
And if you're on there, you
can always ask questions.
You'll get live answers.
Thanks so much
for being with us.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yeah, we
especially appreciate
if you are one of the
viewing parties from all
over the world.
Thanks a lot for
staying with us.
KIT MERKER: Hashtag
#GCPNEXT is our handle.
Go ahead and hit that one.
And let's go look at
the main stage, yes?
[MUSIC PLAYING]